what connects your happiness everything
you do is connected to who you are as a
person and in turn creates the person
you are becoming Paul eemiller
offer known for his books on
spirituality this is where the magic
starts to happen you have your page of
all the things that make you happy right
if not do it now it's important go back
and watch that video I want you to take
action there is one common theme that
connects all the things that make you
happy you might have many reasons why
mrs. Jones with your favorite teacher
there could be 10 things you love about
your favorite movies the people you hang
out with have lots of different
personalities but there is one theme
that unites them all one thing they
together share this is the connective
tissue that will make all your future
decisions easier this is a powerful
mantra that will give you a sense of
purpose and help you change the world
for the better
this is your one word find the common
theme in the list of things that make
you happy and write it down if it
doesn't pop off the page the next to
each the things that make you happy
right why you like it you'll notice a
pattern that emerges some words will
come up over and over again take the
words you lose most commonly to describe
your happiest moment and group them
together if you can't get it down to one
word yet don't worry just try to get the
final list from this exercise down to
five words or fewer now we can take the
next step in building your extraordinary
life and business
you
you